The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to
Lecture Number 10.
In this lecture, I would like
to discuss a solution of
dynamic equilibrium equations.
And in particular, I would like
to talk about the direct
integration solution of the
equilibrium equations in
dynamic analysis.
These, of course, are the
equilibrium equations that we
derived already earlier.
M as a mass matrix, C as a
damping matrix, K as a
stiffness matrix, U as a
displacement vector, and here
we have the velocities and the
accelerations at the null points.
R, of course, being the load
vector and this load vector is
now time dependent.
I also should draw your
attention on the fact that I
would like to talk about direct
integration of these equations.
We will talk about the modes
of opposition procedures in
the next lecture.
By direct integration, we mean
that we integrate these
equations directly without--
that is, without--
a transformation of these
equations into a different
form prior to the integration.
In modes of opposition analysis,
now you will see in
the next lecture, we're actually
transforming these
equations first, and then we
integrate the response.
So the procedures that I'd
like to talk about are
explicit, implicit integration
procedures that directly
operate on these equations
without a transformation and
integrate, solve these
equations.
I also would like to talk
about some computational
considerations with regard to
these explicit and implicit
integration procedures, the
number of operations involved,
the costs involved in
performing these
integrations and so on.
And then there is an important
consideration, namely the
selection of the solution
time step, delta-t.
We will see that when we
integrate the dynamic
equilibrium equations, we have
to select the time step
delta-t with which we perform
the integration.
And this time step has to be
selected in order to preserve
stability of the integration and
to preserve of course or
to obtain accuracy in
the integration.
Finally, I'd like to talk
about some modeling
considerations pertaining to
the solution of the dynamic
equilibrium equations.
Well, here on this view graph,
I'm showing once again the
dynamically equilibrium
equations here, noticing once
more that R, the load vector,
is now a function of time.
The same equations here have
been rewritten once here,
where FI denotes inertia
forces, now time
dependent, of course.
The mass matrix is constant,
but the accelerations of
course depend on time.
Then this part here, which are
the damping forces, has been
expressed here as FD a function
of time again.
The C matrix is constant with
time, but the velocities, of
course, vary with time.
So here we have damping
forces.
It's a nodes of the finite
element system.
And these are the elastic
forces, KU, which are really
due to the internal
element stresses.
And on the right hand side, we
have the external forces.
So what we're saying is that
we want to solve this force
equilibrium over all times t.
The inertia forces plus the
damping forces plus the
elastic forces, it's the nodes
of the finite element system,
of course, calculated in the
virtual work sense, the way
we've been talking about in
the earlier lectures.
The sum of these forces here
must be equal to the
externally applied
nodal point logs.
Well, the procedure
that we will be
following is the following.
We will consider time steps
delta-t a part at which we
want to calculate the response
of the system.
In order to do so, of
course, we have to
define our loads first.
And here, I have schematic shown
once the description of
the load Ri, that is, the load
at degree of freedom i as a
function of time t.
Notice that we are having here
this distribution of that load
component as a function
of time.
The distribution is
quite simple.
In a computer program, of
course, all we would have to
put in is this point, this
intensity here, that load
intensity, at a specified
time.
That load intensity, at a
specified time, and that load
intensity at a specified time.
In between, these intensities,
the computer program would
simply interpolate linearly.
This is the load at the
component i, displacement
component i.
This is the load at displacement
component j.
Notice here, of course, we
would have in general a
different curve at degree of
freedom j, then the curve is
used at degree of freedom i.
I show here time steps, discrete
time steps, delta-t1,
delta-t2, delta-t3.
These of course apply for the
complete system, for the i
component and the j component of
displacements or loads, and
for all other displacements
and loads also.
Notice that they can
vary with time.
In many analysis, however, we
simply pick one time step and
keep it constant all along.
The objective is
the following.
In the direct integration of the
equations of equilibrium,
the objective is knowing
the initial conditions.
In other words, knowing the
displacement at time 0, the
velocities at time 0.
We want to calculate the
displacements, velocities, and
accelerations at these
discrete time points.
We are matching here with the
time interval delta-t1.
And here we are changing the
time interval to delta-t2.
Knowing all the velocities,
accelerations, and
displacement at this time, we
want to calculate the same
quantities at the discrete
time increments of
delta-t2, and so on.
So basically what we are saying
is that knowing the
initial conditions, we want to
calculate in a step-by-step
procedure, the displacements,
velocities, and accelerations
at these discrete time points.
Of course, the real problem then
reduces to the following.
Given the initial conditions at
the particular time t, we
might call this time t, and by
initial conditions, I mean we
know the displacements,
velocities, accelerations, we
know all the quantities
at time t.
Our objective is to calculate
the unknown quantities at time
t plus delta-t1 in this
particular case.
So this point is t
plus delta-t1.
In general, or in many cases, we
keep a constant time step,
and so we will simply
talk about t plus
delta-t from now onwards.
We should remember, however, the
delta-t might change doing
the response solution.
I repeat once more, this is an
important point, given the
initial conditions or given the
conditions at time t, our
objective is to calculate the
conditions, displacements,
velocities, accelerations,
at time t plus delta-t.
In the explicit integration,
we proceed in
the solution as follows.
We use the equations of dynamic
equilibrium at time t
to obtain the solution at
time t plus delta-t.
This is important.
In explicit integration, we
use the condition, the
equilibrium equations, the
equilibrium equation, the
dynamic equilibrium equation,
and by that I mean, just to
refresh your memory, this
equation-- we use that
equation at time t in explicit
integration to obtain the
solution at time
t plus delta-t.
Once we have the solution at
time t plus delta-t, of course
we can march ahead in
the same way again.
In implicit integration,
however, we are looking at the
equilibrium equations at time t
plus delta-t t to obtain the
solution at time
t plus delta-t.
In other words, if you look at
once more at the equations
here, at the equilibrium
equations, these equations
would be applied at time t plus
delta-t to obtain the
solution at time
t plus delta-t.
This is indeed the fundamental
difference between explicit
and implicit integration.
In explicit integration, we
are looking at equilibrium
equations at time t to
obtain the solution
at time t plus delta-t.
And in implicit integration,
we are looking at the
equilibrium equations at time
t plus delta-t to attain the
solution at time
t plus delta-t.
In the following now, I would
like to show to you an
explicit and an implicit
integration scheme.
The explicit integration scheme
that is abundantly used
in practice is the central
difference method.
I will later on then discuss
how this method
is effectively used.
In the central difference
method, we are applying, as I
said earlier, the equilibrium
equations at time t, because
it's an explicit integration
scheme.
The two additional questions
that we're using to solve for
the unknown displacements at
time t plus delta-t, is
firstly an equation for the
accelerations at time t.
And notice that this equation
involves as the unknown, as
the only unknown,
the displacement
at time t plus delta-t.
In addition, of course, we are
using an equation for the
velocities at time t and again
this equation only involves as
the only unknown the
displacement
at time t plus delta-t.
Substituting these two equations
into the equilibrium
equation at time t gives us one
equation in the unknown t,
displacement at time
t plus delta-t.
We can simply solve for
it, as shown, now on
the next view graph.
You can see here the equation
that is obtained by
substituting the relations for
the acceleration and for the
velocities in the equilibrium
equation at time t.
The unknown appears here.
This is the displacement
at time t plus
delta-t, which is unknown.
And there is a coefficient
matrix here, that involves the
mass matrix and the
damping matrix.
And on the right hand side, of
course, we are calculating a
load vector.
And that load vector, notice
once again, corresponds to the
conditions at time t.
That's why it's an explicit
integration scheme.
The difference operator, the
essential difference operator
that I've been used here, simple
operators which you
have seen on the previous slide,
that involve only the
displacement at time t
minus delta-t and the
displacement at time t.
And notice that here
are these two
displacement vectors appearing.
Notice that this equation
is cheaply--
or can be used in a very cheap
way to calculate the
displacement, the unknown
displacement at time t plus
delta-t, if the mass matrix
is a diagonal matrix.
And, say, the damping
is neglected.
In other words, this term not
being there, this being a
diagonal mass matrix, then the
solution is very trivial.
In fact, all we need to do is
calculate the right hand side
load vector and divide each
component of that load vector
by this coefficient here which,
if m once again is a
diagonal mass matrix,
is simply Mii
divided by delta-t squared.
And in fact, this is really
how was the procedure is
usually applied, namely,
with a diagonal mass
matrix and no damping.
The damping usually is not
taken into account, or at
most, we have diagonal dampers
also, and the mass matrix
being a diagonal matrix,
then the solution is
very cheaply performed.
There's one further
important point.
This load vector of course is
constructed in the usual way.
This multiplication here is
quite cheap if the mass matrix
is a diagonal mass matrix.
K times tU.
Well, K here is of course
a banded matrix.
It's the stiffness matrix
of the system, constant.
Well, there are some operations
involved here.
And if we look at this operation
here in detail, we
see here how it can be
effectively performed.
We have a stiffness
matrix times the
displacement vector here.
And of course, the stiffness
matrix remember is obtained by
summing the element
contributions.
So you can write this K
matrix in this way.
Since tU is independent of the
elements, we can also take it
into the summation sign.
And if we look at this product
closely, we find that is
nothing else than tFm.
It's a nodal point vector of
loads or elements forces that
correspond--
element elastic forces-- that
correspond to the current
displacements.
And this tF vector is much more
cheaply calculated than
the Km times tU.
And in fact, this is the way
how we actually perform the
calculation of this
product here.
Now notice the following
important further point.
If we were to leave this K times
tU the way it stands
here, we would have to assemble
a global stiffness
matrix of the system.
However, if we write that
product this way, we never
need to assemble a global
stiffness matrix
of the total system.
In fact, all we need to do is
calculate element forces and
add these elements forces via
the direct stiffness procedure
the way I've been discussing
earlier.
So this is a very effective way
of calculating K times tU.
We never need to assemble a
global stiffness matrix.
In fact, this is one of the main
reasons why the central
difference method
is effective.
It's this reason that we can
calculate the KtU part, this
times that, very effectively
via this procedure.
That is the first reason.
And the second reason is that
if M is diagonal, we really
never solve equations.
The equation solving here is so
trivial, that we might just
say that we do not
solve equations.
There is no factorization
involved.
There's no factorization of a
stiffness matrix or another
coefficient matrix involved,
because if M is diagonal, and
as I pointed out, we simply
divide the right hand side by
Mii divided by delta-t
squared.
Notice that if we start the
integration process, we know
of course the initial
conditions.
We know tU.
And we do not know--
usually directly the
t minus delta-tU.
That is the displacement
prior to the solution.
And to obtain those, we can
use this formula, which is
really the central difference
method applied at time t,
where we however now involve
the accelerations
corresponding to time 0.
We involve the accelerations
corresponding to time zero
right here, and the velocities
corresponding to times 0, and
the displacements corresponding
to time zero.
And of course, these quantities
must all be given
as the initial conditions
to the solution.
I pointed out already that we're
using this technique
mostly with the lump
mass matrix.
In addition I should also point
out that we're using it
primarily with lower
order elements,
with lower order elements.
The reason for that is the
following, namely, one of
stability and accuracy of the
central difference method.
The method can only be applied
if delta-t, the time step that
I'm talking about here,
is smaller than a
critical time step.
And that critical time step is
given by the smallest period
in the system divided by
pi, 3.14 et cetera.
The smallest period in
the system can be
of course very small.
And therefore the critical time
step that we're talking
about here can be very small.
The smallest period in the
system, just to give you an
example, would be extremely
small if you have a bar
element, and you have
some very short
truss element in there.
The shorter the truss element,
the stiffer of course it is.
AU over L is the stiffness
of a truss element, and
therefore, a very small period
would be in that
assemblage of elements.
Therefore, what is required
really is to have a mesh that
is more or less uniform, so that
there is no artificially
small time step required in
the integration of the
equilibrium equations.
Because there is this
condition that
delta-t must be smaller--
we should really say must
be smaller or equal--
to delta-t critical, but to be
on the conservative side, we
are selecting delta-t smaller
than delta-t critical in
practical analysis of
complex meshes.
Because this condition has to
be satisfied, we're talking
about a conditionally
stable scheme.
It is only stable when delta-t
is smaller than that value.
If we were to select delta-t
larger than delta-t critical,
we would see that after just a
few time steps, the solution--
it gets out of bounds.
And after 10 or 20 or 30 time
step, in a computer program,
you would all of
a sudden notice
overflow of the numbers.
So the solution wouldn't make
any sense whatsoever anymore.
And this is an absolute
condition that
does have to be satisfied.
There's no way you can use a
time step larger than delta-t
critical, and still get an
acceptable, reasonable
solution to your equations
of motion.
In practice, of course, we
have to estimate, in a
conservative way, a time step.
And that means we have
to have an estimate
also of delta-t critical.
For continuum elements--
by continuum elements, I mean
plain stress, plain strain,
axis a matrix, three-dimensional
element, the
way we have been discussing
it earlier.
A good way of obtaining time
step delta-t is to use this
formula here, delta-t being
delta-L over C. C is the wave
velocity through the system.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is divided by rho, square root
out of it gives us C. And
delta-L is an element length
that has to be defined.
In fact, it's the smallest
distance between nodes.
The smallest distance between
nodes if we talk about low
order elements.
What I mean by that
is the following.
If we have a mesh here
that looks like that.
And I deliberately show elements
that are not equal in
size, then delta-E in this
particular case would be this
distance here.
That is our delta-L, sorry,
our delta-L is
that distance there.
This, of course, as I have here
in the heading, assumes
that we have low-order
elements.
That means only corner nodes
in the elements.
For higher-order elements--
let me put down here one
higher-order element, where we
have these nodes now, say
an 8 node element.
In this particular case, we
take the smallest distance
between nodes, again, just
as in this case.
And in this particular case,
it would be, say, this
distance here.
That is our smallest distance
between nodes.
However, we have to also divide
this distance by a
relative stiffness factor.
And why does that relative
stiffness factor
come into the picture?
Well, it does come into the
picture, because remember that
the stiffness at an interior
node is larger than the
stiffness at a corner
for the element.
The amount it is larger depends
on the particular
element used.
But since there's a lot of
stiffness here, we have to put
here a relative stiffness factor
into the calculation of
delta-L, the effective lengths
that we're using in this
particular formula.
Now, for this element here,
for example, the relative
stiffness factor would
be conservatively
just equal to 4.
But for other elements, and
particular also when there's
node shifting involved and so
on, the relative stiffness
factor has to be calculated,
has to be estimated.
And we should always remember
that it should be estimated
here in a conservative way,
because a smaller delta-L gave
us a smaller delta-t.
And then we are then
conservatively applying the
fact that delta-t shall be
smaller than the delta-t
critical, value that I have
been referring hereto.
The method is used mainly for
wave propagation analysis.
The reason being that we have
to use a fairly large number
of time steps to predict
the solution.
Large, because a time step
delta-t is usually very small.
And in wave propagation
analysis, many modes of the
system are being excited.
So we really want to pick
up a large number of
modes in the mesh.
And the small time step
integrating accurately many
modes in the mesh goes together
with the fact that we
want to predict many modes in
the mesh or a large number of
modes in the mesh, and therefore
the method is
effectively used for wave
propagation analysis.
The number of operations are
proportional to the number of
elements that we are using and
the number of time steps.
Of course, this is an
approximate proportionality
here that I'm talking about.
This fact derives directly from
the consideration that we
talked about here.
Notice that as we include more
and more elements in the
solution process, of course,
we have to sum over more
elements here.
And as we go more and more time
steps, we have to apply
this equation as many times
also more and more.
The important point is that we
don't assemble a K matrix, so
the bandwidth off the system,
the bandwidth of the system
does not appear in an
operation count.
It's the number of elements
that do appear in the
operation count.
The next procedure that
I like to talk about
is the Newmark method.
And in the Newmark method,
this being an implicit
integration scheme now,
we proceed as follows.
We apply--
because it's an implicit
integration scheme--
the equilibrium equation, the
dynamic equilibrium equation
at time t plus delta-t.
Here it is given the additional
formula that we're
using is this one here for the
velocity at time t plus
delta-t, and this one here for
the displacement of time t
plus delta-t.
Now notice that with this set of
equations, with these three
equations, knowing the
displacements and velocities
at time t and accelerations at
time t, we have with these
three equations,
three unknowns.
The velocity at time t plus
delta-t, the acceleration at
time t plus delta-t, and
the displacement
at time t plus delta-t.
These are the only three
unknowns that appear.
There are three linearly
independent equations.
And we can simply use them to
calculate these three unknowns.
Of course, we want to do so
in a very effective way.
And I will show you
how we proceed.
The important point is that with
this scheme, we are using
an implicit approach, as
I defined it earlier.
And when we do substitute from
here into there, we will find
that on the left hand side, we
have a coefficient matrix that
involves a bandwidth even if the
mass matrix is diagonal.
And this coefficient matrix
here is written
here down as K hat.
This coefficient matrix
invoice this K matrix.
I should say maybe a few words
to these formulae.
These formulae can be obtained
by Taylor Series expansion,
around the conditions at
times t plus delta-t.
They have been proposed
originally by Newmark.
That's why it's called now
the Newmark method.
Newmark in particular used the
values of delta equals 1/2 and
alpha equal to 1/4.
And then it's a constant average
acceleration scheme.
The constant average
acceleration schemes use these
values as I pointed out
already earlier.
The method is unconditionally
stable.
This means that the time step
delta-t does not to have to be
smaller than a certain value,
as it was the case in the
central difference method.
The method is primarily was
for analysis of structural
dynamic problems.
I will talk about why
this is so just now.
And the number of operations
that we're talking about here
are an initial factorization
of the K hat matrix.
This is the K hat matrix, And
that initial factorization
involves this K matrix, so the
bandwidth of the K hat matrix
is the same as the bandwidth
of the K matrix.
And therefore the operations
here are one half NM squared.
And for each solution, in time,
because this equation
here has to be solved for each
time step, you're starting
with delta-t, and then we go
to 2 delta-t, 3 delta-t, 4
delta-t, and so on.
And since this solution is to be
formed for each time step,
however, remember the
factorization is only done
once because this K hat matrix
is independent of the time.
Therefore, we have a forward
reduction and back
substitution in each
time step.
And the number of operations in
each time step are 2nm. t
is the number of time
steps here.
t is the number of
time steps here.
Well, let us look then
at the accuracy
considerations that we have.
I mentioned already the method
is unconditionally stable,
which means that the delta-t
time step that we're using can
be any amount, and we will never
have a blow up of the
solution, a blow up of the
solution due to round-off
errors that I involved.
In the central difference
method, of course, the
explicit time integration
scheme, I mentioned that
delta-t has to be smaller than
a critical time step.
So in the implicit Newmark
integration scheme, what we
can do is we select our of
time step based solely on
accuracy considerations.
Let us consider then these
equations that we want to
solve, and I'm now leaving out
the damping term in order to
obtain some understanding of how
we would select the time
step, delta-t.
Of course, remember the larger
the time step, the less normal
operations I involved
in the solution.
So we want to select the
large time step.
However, if we make the time
step extremely large, then
surely we cannot expect any
accuracy in the solution.
In fact, if delta-t is very
large, we simply predict the
static solution.
This is one property of
the Newmark method.
If you were to use a computer
program with the Newmark
method, if you're interested in
it, why don't you try, say,
for example, using ADINA, in
which we have the Newmark
method, and just put delta-t
very large, and all you would
be getting out is a
static solution.
Well, since we're interested
in the dynamic response, we
have to therefore select
delta-t small enough to
integrate accurately the
solution response.
And these are the equations that
I want to now consider,
and I want to show you how can
we select delta-t rationally
and to obtain the required
accuracy.
The displacement vector here can
be expressed in terms of
the mode shape vectors
times xi values.
I will be talking about how
these phi i vectors are
calculated in the
next lectures.
This involves the solution
of the eigenvalue problem
written down here.
The free vibration eigenvalue
a problem corresponding to
this equation.
I like to defer the discussion
at this point, because we will
be talking about it later
on in detail.
All I like to say is that this
transformation here, phi i
being a vector time independent
and xi being a
scalar, dependent on time.
This transformation can be used
in this solution here, or
can be used rather to transform
this system of
equations into a
different form.
And in that transformation, we
use the fact that when we
calculate phi transpose
K times 5--
notice these are capital phis.
I've crossed bars here,
capital phis.
This is a lower phi, no crossed
bars top and bottom.
This capital phi here stores
all of the lowercase phi
vectors, and their n
of such vectors.
If I use this capital phi and
calculate this product here, I
get a diagonal matrix.
In fact, the diagonal matrix
here stores on its diagonal
the frequency squared, the free
vibrational frequency squared.
Also phi transposed M phi gives
us an identity matrix.
These, once again, the vectors
in this matrix, capital phi,
are these phi i vectors
which are the
eigenvectors of this problem.
And I will talk later on about
how we calculate them.
Well, if we apply this
transformation--
whoops, let me put it right once
more-- if we apply this
transformation to this system of
equations, and we use this
property right here, we
obtain n decoupled
equations of this form.
X double ought i plus omega
i squared, xi equals phi i
transposed times R. And they
are in such equations, in
other words I run
c from 1 to n.
In fact, if we use multiple
position analysis, we actually
perform this transformation.
What I now want to do is
simply refer to it
theoretically.
I do not want to transform it.
You're talking about direct
integration of the solution of
equations, in which there is
no transformation involved.
So I do not want to go through
this transformation.
However, I want to refer
to it theoretically.
And it gives me a tremendous
insight into what happens.
So basically, what I can say
theoretically is that the
direct step-by-step solution of
this system of equations,
using the explicit integration
scheme, the central difference
method, or the Newmark implicit
integration scheme,
corresponds completely to the
direct step-by-step solution
of n equations, of this form,
where the displacements here,
U, are given in this way.
x being now a function of time,
so if I differentiate
here, your double dot would be
obtained by differentiating xi
also twice, with respect
to time.
Once again, this is
an important,
very important, fact.
I look at these equations, and
I say that's a solution of
these set of coupled
differential equations.
It's completely equivalent to
the solution of n equations of
this form with this
transformation used.
No dots here or dots there.
In other words, this equation
holds for displacements
without the red dots and
for the accelerations
with the red dots.
It is equivalent.
This solution is equivalent
to that solution.
However, in direct integration,
I never perform
actually the transformation.
All I know is that when I
operate on this system of
equations, using the Newmark
method or the central
difference method, I, in
fact, operate on n
such decoupled equations.
That's important.
And this means that for an
analysis on our direct
integration scheme, we can in
fact analyze our direct
integration scheme by looking at
these equations, instead of
these equations.
You see if I were to analyze my
direct integration scheme
using these equations, I would
have to deal with this huge
matrix K, the huge matrix M. All
I now need to deal with,
in the analysis of the direct
integration scheme, is with n
such simple one degree
of freedom equations.
And in fact, I don't even need
to deal with n such equations,
for the analysis purpose, I
only need to deal with one
equation, where I
make now omega a
variable and r a variable.
So my analysis on this
equation, using this
particular time integration
scheme that I want to analyze,
is completely giving me all the
information that I need to
know when I use my direct
integration scheme in the
solution of this equation.
For analysis purposes of my
direct integration scheme, I
can simply analyze my direct
integration scheme using this
equation and get all
the relevant
information from that analysis.
This is an extremely
important fact.
Once again, I do not actually do
perform the transformation.
We don't do the transformation.
Only in theory for analysis
purposes.
I'm looking at the solution
of this equation using the
Newmark integration scheme.
And I get all the relevant
information on the accuracy,
stability, et cetera of the
integration scheme by looking
at the solution of this equation
with that direct
integration scheme.
Now, even in the analysis
of this
equation, of course, remember--
or in the use of this equation,
remember that r is
available now.
And I have some choice what
to put in there and so on.
But the important point is that
what I want to identify
is the characteristics of
the integration scheme.
And the characteristics of the
integration scheme are really
quite well seen already if we
look at a very simple case,
namely this case.
I set r deliberately
equal to zero.
And I look at the case where I
have initial condition x, the
displacements being one, the
velocities being zero.
this means, of course, that the
accelerations are minus
omega squared.
If I use the Newmark method, the
one that I just talked to
you about, on that system of
equations, then I can plot
errors that reside in
that integration.
And what I've plotted here the
percentage period elongation,
pe divided by t times 100, which
is this amount here that
we see when we integrate the
differential equation that I
showed you via as the Newmark
method with different delta-t
over t values.
On the bottom here, we are
plotting delta-t divided by t,
the period t, of course, being
given for the particular
oscillator that we're
looking at.
We are starting off with one.
The exact solution, I should
take better now another color,
the exact solution would look
something like that,
finishing off here.
That would be the
exact solution.
And what we're seeing now
is an amplitude decay.
It's already there.
It would come in right there.
That is the exact solution.
We'll stop here.
The period is of course
this t here, as shown.
This would be the exact solution
for one period.
What we are seeing as an
amplitude decay, a drop in the
numerical solution, and
period elongation in
the numerical solution.
And the percentage period
elongation is plotted here.
We notice that the Newmark
method corresponds to this
curve here.
So with delta-t over
t being 0.10.
We have about--
let us just look it up here--
we have about 3%, 3%
period elongation
for the Newmark method.
I'm also showing other
techniques here, which are
also implicit techniques, the
Wilson Theta method with Theta
1.4 has about 5% period
elongation for delta-t over t
being 0.10.
Another point of interest
is of course also is the
amplitude decay.
And that amplitude decay is
plotted on this graph here,
percentage amplitude decay
as a function of
delta-t over t again.
Delta-t over t.
And notice that the Newmark
method does not appear.
In fact, the Newmark method
has no amplitude decay.
The solution is right
down here.
No amplitude decay for any
delta-t over t, whereas the
Wilson methods and the Houbolt
method is also shown here,
have the amplitude decay
shown by these curves.
Notice that the Wilson method
has less amplitude decay then
the Houbolt method.
The period elongation for the
Houbolt method was also shown
on this view graph here.
So the Newmark method does have
period elongation, but it
does not have any amplitude
decay in this solution.
I should also mention this, of
course, as one important
point, I forgot to mention that
I'm looking here at the
Newmark method with delta
1/2 alpha equal to 1/4.
This is the constant average
acceleration method.
Well, let us look then
at how can we
actually perform the solution?
How can we select an appropriate
time step delta-t?
Here we notice that the dynamic
load factor that we
are knowing that we can derive
for the solution of this
differential equation here--
here I included damping--
the dynamic load factor plotted
along here as a
functional of p over omega.
p being the exciting free
frequency, omega being the
frequency of the system.
The dynamic load factor
looks as shown here.
If we have no damping, you're
talking about this curve.
Now notice the important
point.
The dynamic load factor, of
course, is 1 for static
response, and it really gives
us a magnification of the
static response.
In a static response, we would
have this solution.
And if the p over omega value
is say 2, we would have that
maximum solution in the dynamic
response analysis.
If p over omega is
equal to 0.5.
we would have, for zero damping,
this maximum solution
in the dynamic response
history.
Or rather this would be the
maximum dynamic response that
you would see in the
dynamic solution.
This is how the dynamic load
factor is defined.
Of course, at p over omega equal
to 1, we have resonance.
In practice, we have always some
damping, and if you look
at this amount of damping, this
would be the maximum with
p over omega equal to 1, we
would have this as the maximum
response that is ever
measured in the
dynamic response solution.
Well, if we look at this graph,
we recognize of course
that as p over omega goes
against 0, in other words as
the exciting frequency, as
over the frequency of the
system goes against 0, we
really talk about static
conditions.
As p over omega is very large,
we are talking about no
response whatsoever.
And the important dynamic
response really lies somewhat
in this region here with that
being the tail end of it.
But the important dynamic
response really lies in here,
that we have to include
in the solution.
Out here we have basically
a static response.
Let us look at two
simple cases.
For p over omega 0.05, we can
see that the static response
here shown in a dashed line, the
dynamic response showing
as a solid line.
They're basically the same.
In other words, a dynamic
response being equal to the
static response, practically
equal to the static response.
We are down at this
range here.
As another example, if we have
p over omega equal to 3, we
are down over here.
Then the response, the static
response is shown here in the
dashed line, and the dynamic
response is shown
as the solid line.
Very little response
here at all.
Because as p over omega goes
to infinity, there is no
response for the system
at all anymore.
Basically, what we're saying
then is that the frequency of
the applied loading is
so fast, that the
structure can;t just move.
It just cannot move at all.
And we don't have any response
in the structure.
Well, the important point is
that if we know the frequency
content of the loading, then
what we have to do in the use
of the Newmark method is to
calculate a delta-t small
enough to pick up the loading,
of course, because that is
given in terms of this great
steps or this great input
points to the computer program,
and the time step has
to be small enough to integrate
the dynamic response
of importance accurately.
The static response, the static
response is contained
in the solution anyway, because
the K matrix is on the
left hand side of
the solution.
So the complete solution process
therefore can be
summarized as follows.
Identify the frequencies
contained in the loading, and
using a Fourier analysis,
if necessary.
Choose a finite element mesh
that accurately represents all
frequencies up to about four
times the highest frequency
omega u contained
in the loading.
The highest frequency contained
in the loading is
really the cutoff frequency that
will give us a time step.
And that then, the time step is
in fact obtained via these
consideration.
Perform a direct integration
analysis.
The time step delta-t for this
solutions should equal about 1
over 20 Tu, where Tu is 2 pi
over omega u, which is the
highest frequency contained
in the loading.
What we are saying basically
is that we want to select a
finite element mesh to
represent the highest
frequency in the loading
correctly, accurately, and
then we want to select a time
step in the data integration
solution using the Newmark
method that integrates the
highest frequency contained in
the loading also accurately,
or the response in that highest
frequency contained in
the loading also accurately.
And this then gives us basically
a step-by-step
procedure for the selection of
the finite element mesh and
the times step.
Notice that the mesh selection
and the time step selection
both of course hinge on the
structure and the particular
frequency content
of the loading.
That's important.
This is the modeling procedure
that we would use for a
structural vibration problem.
We would use this time step
here in the implicit
integration, because we get
all the accuracy we want.
In an explicit integration,
we would have to use a
smaller time step.
The sentence down here "or be
smaller for stability reasons"
really refers to the explicit
time integration.
In the Newmark method, we would
not use that condition.
We would simply use Tu, being 2
pi omega u and delta-t being
1 over 20 times Tu.
So in the Newmark method, I
blank this out, and this is
here the delta-t that
we would be using.
And just to summarize once the
modeling of wave propagation
problem here, here what we would
do is we assume that the
wavelength is Lw.
The total time for the wave to
travel past a point is then tw
equal Lw over c, where
c is the wave speed.
Assuming that n time steps are
necessary to represent the
wave, we get our delta-t and the
effective length, which I
talked about earlier, of the
finite element would be then
given by this formula.
So the procedure here is
somewhat different in that if
we have a wave that looks like
this say, we now select a
certain number of times steps,
delta-t, to pick up the wave
accurately.
And this being the length Lw,
the time for the wave to
travel past the point is tw.
And delta-t then is the number
of time points, or time steps,
that are used to represent
the wave accurately.
And once we have the time step,
we select the effective
length of an element.
And then, of course it depends
on whether we have a low-order
element or a high-order element,
that will give us
then the procedure of
how to apply the
effective lengths criteria.
I like to finally now summarize
the complete
solution process.
This is a table that I put
together for you to show how
the complete solution process
for explicit and implicit time
integration can be very
effectively implemented in a
computer program.
We form a linear stiffness
matrix K, the mass matrix M,
the damping matrix C, whichever
applicable.
We calculate the following
constants.
If we select the Newmark
method, these are the
constants that you would use.
Let's not go into details.
These constants are given
in the textbook.
They are given in the ADINA
manual, if you are using the
ADINA computer program.
They are widely published.
We simply cast them
in this form.
In the central difference
method, we
would use these constants.
So there is some initialization
involved.
Then in the central difference
method, we also want to
calculate our first
displacement, delta-t U, as
shown here.
And in the Newmark method, we
don't need to do that, because
we simply march ahead from time
t to time t plus delta-t.
You only need the condition at
the conditions at time t to
obtain the solution at
times t plus delta-t.
In the central difference
method, remember we need two
previous values.
We then form an effective linear
coefficient matrix.
In implicit time integration,
this is
the coefficient matrix.
The stiffness matrix
being there, as I
showed to you earlier.
The mass matrix and damping
matrix being there.
If we look at this a0, we
notice that a0 is 1 over
delta-t squared and there's
a constant alpha here.
The Newmark constant.
But it's 1 over delta-t
squared.
That is the important point.
So as delta-t gets larger and
larger, larger and larger,
this effect goes against 0.
The same holds for
the a1 constant.
As delta-t gets larger and
larger, this effect
goes against 0.
And this is the reason why the
Newmark method really goes
down or collapses to the static
analysis, if we have
very large time steps.
In explicit integration, we use
this coefficient matrix.
And now for each integration
step, or for each time step,
we perform the following
calculations.
We calculate the t plus
delta-t R hat.
And implicit time integration,
the Newmark method, in
explicit time integration,
we calculate this vector.
Notice at tF here,
no k times tU.
k times 2u is equal to tF.
In implicit time integration,
having calculated for each
time step this load step, we
now use the equations K hat
times t plus delta-t u, equals
t plus delta-t R hat to
calculate t plus delta-t u.
Of course, we would triangulize
the K hat matrix
prior to going into this loop.
We do it once and forward.
In explicit time integration,
we use this matrix or this
vector here, I should say, this
vector now, and we can
calculate directly for the
t plus delta-t U also.
The two equations that I used
are summarized here.
In implicit time integration,
this is the
equation that we use.
Notice we only need
to factorize this
K hat matrix once.
We do it outside the
step-by-step integration, as I
pointed out earlier.
And then this gives us the
increment in displacements.
In explicit time integration,
this is the equation we use.
If M and C are diagonal, it's
a trivial operation as I
pointed out earlier.
With this then, we have
the new displacements.
And on the last view graph, I
show you the formulae that we
are then using to calculate
the accelerations in the
Newmark method from the
incremental displacements and
variables that we
knew already.
Having now calculated the
accelerations, we can get the
velocities at time
t plus delta-t.
And of course, we have already
our displacement at time t
plus delta-t.
In the central difference
method, we use our basic
equations that we already
applied earlier in the
development of the method to
calculate the velocities and
the accelerations at time t.
This completes the procedure
that is effectively used in a
computer program for the
integration of the dynamic
equilibrium equations.
I like to just now mention
that I've placed heavy
emphasis on the Newmark method
in an implicit integration.
Of course, there are other
implicit integration formulae
available, the Wilson method,
the Houbolt method, and so on.
The Newmark method
has shown, has
proven to be quite effective.
And it's certainly a good
example to demonstrate to you
how the actual procedure is
implemented and how an
implicit integration scheme
is being used.
Other implicit integration
methods would be used in much
the same way.
This is all I wanted to mention
to you, discuss with
you in this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.